la campaña electoral en Brasil le llega
su recta final según el último sondeo
publicado ganaría el ex presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva con el 53% de los
votos válidos es decir sin contar a los
indecisos los votos nulos y en blanco y
el actual presidente
de los votos y los elecciones fuesen hoy
sin embargo hay que recordar que en la
primera vuelta todos los sondeos
Prácticamente subestimaron la fuerza del
bolsonarismo por esta razón entre las
filas de los izquierdistas hay ciertas
dudas de que realmente Lula pueda ganar
en cambio hemos notados en nuestros
reportajes que los seguidores de
bolsonaro están muy convencidos de que
va a haber un segundo mandato del
presidente de derecha el domingo
sabremos la verdad sobre estas
elecciones de momento están entre dicho
el estado de minas gerais el segundo más
populoso del país y también el más
disputado porque la ciencia política se
ha demostrado que Quién gana en ese
estado gana en el resto del país y por
esta razón bolsonaro solamente en la
segunda vuelta de la campaña electoral
ha visitado Minas gerais seis veces en
general en las calles vemos mucha
polarización pero también mucho
cansancio los brasileños quieren que ya
pasen estas elecciones para centrarse en
el otro gran evento del año que es el
mundial de fútbol